pour sa 23ème édition le challenge des
créateurs d'entreprise n'a pas failli à
la règle
plus d'une centaine de candidats se sont
présentés pour le speed casting règle
sanitaire oblige les candidats ont été
convoqués par groupe de 10 avec
distanciation et isolement à chaque
passage c'est une très belle surprise de
voir que malgré toutes ces difficultés
les chefs d'entreprise ont toujours
répondu présent qu'il ya de l'espoir que
qui a pas de fatalité que malgré la
crise malgré les situations difficiles
au départ sociale des personnes on peut
toujours croire à l'insertion par la
création de son propre emploi et ça fait
partie effectivement des solutions de la
station durable et pérenne qui se
perpétue la crise top départ
allez-y à ce moment là les chefs
d'orchestre de ces tpe se met en
mouvement
[Musique]
c'était soit thérapeutique choisi des
chemins creux de la permaculture qu'ils
soient industriels gratuitement mieux
financés pour l'heure plus deux
entreprises c'était super c'était dans
ont été dans les échanges dans le
partage dans l' écoute il fait trouve sa
voix lasse et c'est déjà beaucoup
on est à des richesses ici ben savoir à
faire afin de mettre en valeur une cadre
la tradition si l'iphone et pistaches
higuain effet 21 élèves arrivent de la
mode de la modernisation en même temps
si aussi montré que ben malgré mais du
haut de mes 25 ans j'ai réussi dans ma
vie malgré les échecs malgré tout ce
qu'on les étiquettes qu'on pose sur soi
quel que soit le résultat l'avenir ces
deux bêtes de continuer déjà à
travailler enfin essayez de moi parce
qu'avec la crise qu vite c'est compliqué
mais de s'y reconnaître
et d'avancer de s'améliorer à
l'enthousiasmé salué par ce jury de
professionnels acteurs de terrain du
réseau point chance
de quoi garantir le succès d'une
opération essentielle qui valorise ses
parcours d'insertion dans la création de
leur propre emploi ils sont assez posé
assez serein
malgré le contexte économique qui frappe
de plein fouet pas mal d'activités
aujourd'hui
enfin on ressent chez eux une une
confiance en l'avenir une reprise dans
les quelques mois qui arrivent
objectif est sélectionnée parmi les 14
finalistes dans cette catégorie et
remporter ces nombreux coups de pouce
les résultats sont maintenant
disponibles sur le site du département
après la réalisation de portraits de ces
entrepreneurs une dernière sélection
déterminera chaque lauréat
[Musique]